if you're thinking about it we're
talking about it
it's all about me that was a joke
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Piers Morgan uncensored he's
one of the smartest and richest men in
music history kiss Legend Gene Simmons
gives me his lessons from an
extraordinary Life we'll talk money
power Showbiz Scandal politics and love
he's had it all strap in is going to be
a crazy uncensored night
[Music]
thank you
from the news building in London this is
Piers Morgan uncensored well good
evening welcome to a special edition of
Piers Morgan uncensored last time my
guest was here a few weeks ago I left
wanting a lot more I thought why aren't
we doing a whole hour with this guy so I
asked him he couldn't understand why we
went either so he's agreed and he's back
for the whole hour tonight a true living
legend of rock one on one
Gene Simmons is rock and roll royalty
kiss have more gold certified records
than any other band on the planet
selling 75 million records in half a
century of touring and two months from
rags to Richards Gina's turning beats
into a business Empire he's got the
longest tongue in rock and one of the
sharpest tongues in politics they called
him Dr love the demon the God of Thunder
is quite possibly the world's smartest
ever rock star and tonight Gene Simmons
is uncensored
I've actually got a stinking cold and so
my first question was going to be when
you're a singer what do you do when you
get a stinking cold and you're on tour I
never claimed to be a singer what we do
is we just pile through it the kind of
music we do is certainly not operatic
and uh we don't pretend to be on X
Factor or any of that stuff you ever
lost your voice
no not in the way people think of it
it's uh because you just kind of plow
through it it's more uh you know sort of
gut kind of thing and I see that's a
jagger does the smart thing as well you
write songs in your vocal range without
very many high notes or very low so you
can you can do it even if your voice is
good can you ever had to cancel a show
for sickness you
kiss no you have you ever been
responsible for a show
no in your entire career no never and
that's because
look this is a this is a blessing I
don't want to get too cornball about it
but by the way I look pretty good
uh
the the idea that God or whomever is in
charge would give me a chance to lead
this kind of life it's just unbelievable
you know we're approaching 50 years uh
this year and this journey has been just
beyond anything so the least you could
do is show up on time
love and respect the fans and understand
that what you do isn't necessary food
shelter those are necessary things but
the people that stick their tongue out
and act like you know the the Court
Jester that's not necessary for Life as
we know it on the planet let me take you
back 50 years your first show in the UK
which received the following review from
a gentleman called Tony Wilson who went
on to be of course a factory records
Legends this is what he said about your
first show when you first popped up you
guys
between heavy metal perhaps it should be
illegal it's not all one way if we gave
the states the idea of music as physical
assault then they just repaid the
compliment with such bands as kiss who
had the same effect as using brillo pads
to get rid of acne can you also play
music
[Applause]
you project evil the question is I mean
is there any evil in you
did you play football at school
[Music]
what do you feel looking at that
I if that was a new band I'd be
interested gee they look like yeah
they're having a lot of sighting
different exciting different and that
was the idea because we were such big
anglophiles uh American music to us was
just boring I mean I know America
created blues and rock and eventually
rap and all that but what the English
did this little island I know it
comprises Wales and all the other
wonderful countries but this little
island gave the world the music that
stands the test of time the Beatles and
the kiss and we wanted to form a band
sort of like
The Beatles on steroids where everybody
in the band sang Everybody Was a star
every now of course we couldn't Shine
the Beatles shoes I'm not saying we're
anywhere near in that League nor would
we pretend to be but the idea the
template was that as opposed to the
stones where there's one guy in the
front and the guys are in the back and
what what an amazing life I still can't
believe it let me take you back to the
very start of this amazing life because
that in itself is truly extraordinary
and I think was the pivot really for
everything that followed and that's your
mother who was this remarkable woman who
at the age of 14 in World War II we've
got a picture of you with her there I
think you're about eight years old when
she was 14 she was taken into
concentration camps three in in the end
in World War II by the Nazis somehow
survived and will come to that
and then left at 19 having lost most
formative years of her life in this
appalling Holocaust
how much of an impact did that have not
just on her but on you
well look I uh
I was born in Israel I
um I didn't know anything about history
or life or anything it's just that I
knew that my mother was there uh our
father my father see even our I didn't
want to personalize it my father left us
when I was about six or seven years of
age and unfortunately it's fairly common
fathers just pick up and leave shameful
as it is
and all I had was my mother and I was
the only child and she was my rock she
was my the foundation my moral compass
but I didn't know anything about my
mother she wouldn't talk about her
formative years hungry where she and my
father were born and never talked about
the concentration camps and as I got
older I tried to engage Mom I'm now a
sixth grade teacher in Spanish Harlem
and I know a little bit about the
history can you tell me she wouldn't do
it it was just too horrific and uh you
later discovered a lot of stuff about
what she'd been through from the
archives what did you find out about a
time in the concentration my mother at
14 13 14 had gone to frisor which is a
school for to learn how to do makeup and
hair and stuff like that and the way my
mother survived almost almost to the t
is what Sophie's Choice at Meryl Streep
movie is the common dance wife and the
concentration camp at matthausen I found
out
um her she wanted somebody who knew how
to do makeup and hair and stuff like
that so she brought some Jews in you
know Jewish girls any one of you and
they had a row of young uh Jewish women
and Country sweat and Deutsche I can
speak a little German I made sure I
learned how to speak that language
currency Spartan Deutsch
do Z
and a few of the girls said uh you know
here comes back in the business Deutsch
and they throw them out God knows what
happened to them my mother who could get
by in German actually didn't raise her
hands because she understood the less I
know I'm going to keep quiet and because
my mother they thought couldn't speak
German she was allowed to stay there and
do the hair for the commandant's wife
and so on and would sneak you know a
piece of bread or some old chicken the
garbage pail and that's how she survived
astonishingly and she and she told me
when I finally confronted her about that
she told me she didn't dare mention this
to anybody when she got back to the
barracks because she would be killed I
would be killed for the morsels of food
as hard it is to believe but and she
lost a large number of a family I have
no grandparents I didn't know anybody
her brother everybody and before she
later admitted my mother lived to be 94
years of age
and always told me every day above
ground is a good day you know in
Hungarian
and i t i take that with me wherever I
go uh blessed and her mother my
grandmother who I've never met was being
led off to the gas Chambers with her
mother they took the oldest first and my
mother's mother would not let her mother
go to the gas chamber by herself she
willingly walked with her
and in essence turned to my mother in
Hungarian and said live
uh survive and my name in in Hebrew is
Haim which means life
live you know it's the greatest gift
there is and uh
and that's you know despite everything
despite the hardships my mother's point
of view about life and everything was
enjoy the little things this glass of
water and thank you for this by the way
I'll take a little bit the water the
thing you don't know what you've got
until and if it's gone
every day above ground is a good day you
better tattoo that on your soul right
now she also never and I've interviewed
a lot of Holocaust Survivors
she liked them never had a trace of
self-pity no never played the victim no
never talked on anybody's shirt sleeves
do you know what a horrible life I've
had no she refused to speak about it
Stephen Spielberg who we've met a few
times uh reached out for the showa
foundation he wanted to interview the
survivors of the concentration camps and
wanted my mother uh to record her
experiences and she refused it was too
what she saw was beyond anything and of
course there are deniers out there uh
unfortunately and but it's a lesson for
all of us and for those of you that keep
thinking that this is just the Jewish
experience very few people understand
that millions of gypsies Christians
undesirables
the homosexual Community they were
Millions were slaughtered there just
because they were unwanted you have a
very low tolerance of
some of the modern societal traits
entitlement victimhood you know all this
kind of stuff is that driven by what
happened with your mother of course if
you don't have a sense of history and
where you came from and stuff you take
everything for granted this entitlement
thing is a disease of modern pop culture
wokism and so on our kids Nick and
Sophie are the most wonderful human
beings I know of they're much better
than Shannon and I Shannon's right
outside more ethical more moral polite
and all this kind of stuff I can tell I
can tend to push the button sometimes
like you can but for a fact because we
get off on it but they never received a
penny of an allowance this idea of
giving your kids money for not doing
anything is insane so they've never done
that in fact Shannon
drove the kids every day to school
without fail whether she was sick or not
for years and she volunteered to do the
lunch thing so that she can keep an eye
on her two children and Nick our son got
an award the only one they've ever given
for perfect attendance for the first
five years of going to school which oh
here I am talking about kids on the
Pierce Morgan show I'm sorry you're
allowed to I've got four kids I was
proud of them as you are as you as you
know of but go ahead let's take a short
break when I come back I want to talk to
you about the moment you move to America
you and your mum and that starts the
next phase of both your lies and it's an
extraordinary phase we'll talk about
that in a moment
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
dedicating the show tonight to rock
legend and kiss front man Gene Simmons a
gene Europe you're eight years old your
father's walked out on you and your
mother this remarkable woman and she
decides you're going to try your luck
the two of you in America the land of
the free what are your first memories of
when you got to America I remember a
little before we came to America my
mother had two brothers who were able to
escape to America my mother was
in in uh Hungary at the time that she
was
put into the camps and
we I didn't know where we were going I
didn't know what was going on and so my
mother took me to this thing and we
stood in the back of the line and I
didn't know it then but there was a man
sitting on a higher ledge with a desk
and people were lined up and my mother
in her younger years was just a very
very beautiful woman
and the man sitting there with what I
later Learned was the American flag is
uh
you know pointing to my mother in the
back of the line and says something in a
language I never heard of before and we
get to the front of the line and he
tries to communicate with her and he
bends over he's looking done and he says
uh uh do you speak I didn't know what
she was saying he was saying it in
English do you speak English
and he didn't speak Hebrew and he
fumbled and uh
Deutsche can you speak a little German
she says
you know so they start talking a little
bit in in German because he didn't speak
Hebrew
and what I later Learned was
um okay we've got your thing you're
going to America you're going to become
a citizen a few years down the line if
you behave and so on all I need you to
do is to swear Allegiance and some and
raise your hand
this uh sorry I get choked up when I
think about this but uh
my mother didn't
know uh what the guy meant so she did
the only thing that she saw she started
started to do this and uh
I didn't know what was going on and my
mother was you know kind of tearing up
and the man quickly got off
you know the pedestal came over to her
and I'll never forget this um God bless
him
uh he put his right hand above her left
hand uh pushed it down and later my
mother told me he told her you'll never
have to do that ever again wow and
and we came to America and I never saw
or dreamed anything like that the people
were big and everybody had cars and and
uh you know it's just uh and because we
came from dirt roads it was a new
country and there wasn't even an
infrastructure and we visited my aunt
Magda and she had a refrigerator she had
a refrigerator and she opened the
refrigerator it was full of food we
didn't have that you had a piece of
paper like the English fish and chips
you know where you stick it in a piece
of newspaper and stuff and you got your
allotment for the weekend I remember
looking at a jar of jam and in Hungarian
I speak Hungarian as well
and asking my aunt Magda in Hungarian
she too had been in the camps what is
this and she goes you know she gave me a
spoon and opened the thing and she
thought I was going to get a taste and
as soon as I tasted it I started eating
it because I'd never tasted anything
like that and both my mother and my aunt
were were laughing their heads off they
I never saw television I never saw
people flying through the air with capes
and I never saw anything I'm still
Marvel at this amazing country yes it
has its blisters it's racism it's all
kinds of bad things with it but
I think
clearly the UK and so on to start up
started with guy Fox before he tried to
blow up everything and I know but the
history of democracy is the only hope we
have on this planet
you're a perfect example you and your
mother of America taking in pretty much
anyone and giving them the chance of a
different better life which has always
been at its core what the United States
of America is about ideally it's a lot
messier than that I do think that there
is and this always gets me into heart
trouble even though I'm a big proponent
of giving people a chance the world is a
very sad place it's a lot of things but
you've got to have some kind of order
otherwise it's chaos because the good
comes in along with the bad so I believe
in legal immigration just slow it down a
little bit let people at least know your
names where you are social security
number and so on so you can keep track
of what's going on that goes for all the
countries that take in you know sad sad
stories about uh immigrants legal
immigration is
the right way to do it
you there's several things happen to you
one you get bullied as a kid when you
get to America and eventually you fight
back tell me about that moment
I uh I had never been in a fight in in
Israel I was sort of bigger than that
but I'd never been in a fight I didn't
pick on anybody you know Live and Let
Live thing
and I remember
um
being somebody was starting to pick on
me and
I don't remember what happened but it
was a snap it was this kind of uh
uh Jekyll and Hyde thing that had
happened right along and I didn't know
about head butting or anything but I
just hurled my body at this guy who was
two or three years older than I am and
as it happened my forehead uh hit his
face and he went down like an ultra I
didn't know what happened it hurt me I
was just holding my head up and
I thought I was going to be in trouble
with my mother and when I told her about
it
she was proud you know because for the
longest time our people have been you
know a simulationist and you just kind
of don't cause troubles don't fight back
it didn't work out well in World War II
you hate bullies don't you because I
won't stand for it by the way verbal
bullies as well
if you uh if you pick on people
I'm at the front line trying to stop
that because there but for the grace of
God if you allow a group of people or
somebody to be bullied your next pal
yeah everybody everybody is part of a
segment of life and or religion or
culture and so on that that can be
picked on and is picked on so I won't
stand for so you have this moment you
fight back you feel good about yourself
for doing that your mother feels good
about you then you see little later you
see the Beatles on The Ed Sullivan Show
and a light bulb goes off again and
you're thinking not that you want to be
exactly like them because they're a
unique I wish but you wanted you wanted
that
I must have been 13 or 14 years of age
maybe 13 and 1964.
and I'd always worked after school and
it was even on Sundays and it was Sunday
in New York and there was the Ed
Sullivan Show where half the population
of the entire country in America at that
time was 150 million population now it's
330 something million
75 million people watch that show yeah
and the Beatles come out what do you
think you've lost your love you know all
this sound that I never heard before and
I was mesmerized and I thought to myself
gee they look silly in a you know what's
this and they're smaller they're smaller
and slight and they looked you know a
little feminine to uh you know guys
because we're used to you know bigger
guys and my mother comes in and
basically verbalizes the same thing oh
look how silly they look and at that
moment I thought oh they're cool that's
when I started paying attention the
girls were screaming and these guys were
having a good time and I said Gee that's
a good job wish I could do that and when
I first tried to do that I couldn't do
that but I will tell you time to admit
it for a few years
I was 13 until I was about 15 years ago
at 12 o'clock now I did but if I didn't
actually I tried to convince everybody
oh I'm not from here because no do you
know the Beatles
yeah I should be able to all right you
know
did you ever beat the Beatles
um Ringo he sent me a birthday greeting
at uh Paul my partner obviously is Matt
Sir Paul just the most lovely people of
all time you wanna you wanna see
somebody with Grace class after Beetle
Mania and stuff you sit talk with Ringo
or Paul in your seat that's the way you
do it that should be the mark of how to
be gracious I completely agree oh I
think he's an absolute God in that sense
uh you formed kiss I'm not going to go
over the whole history again except to
say that there's a moment
when it all kicks off and you become
this huge band and you're living the
dream that you have when you watch The
Beatles on the O'Sullivan show and you
go to your mother and you have a check
for a million dollars it wasn't a
million how much was it
say it eight eight million eight million
dollars and you show her that check yeah
and how does she respond she didn't
understand it my mother never went to uh
proper school or anything and in
Hungarian you know she just saw the
zeros and stuff and
she literally didn't understand in fact
she used to ask me all the time who pays
you when when do you go to work where do
you go to works because she understood
you go to work at a certain time
somebody pays you I said you know the
people pay me anyway when I showed her
the check I wasn't giving her I said
look look mom look at this money she
didn't understand wonderful wonderful
now what are you going to do
literally because she was worried that
you may just stop working or well I
don't know it was always yesterday it
didn't matter yes and that's a profound
point of view about life which is
there's nothing you can do about
yesterday my mother bless her
wasn't a concentration camp and yet
never referenced that in her dealings
with people today which is incredible
because something you can do about today
and if you can fix today you can make
tomorrow better and my mother was the
funniest person I ever met how is the
orchestra that's how she called yeah
I want to talk about kiss not just the
band but the brand because almost
uniquely you turned kiss into this
money-making machine globally as a brand
as much as a bandit as we see there with
your phone cover so back with Gene
Simmons after the break
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back to my special with Gene
Simmons from Kiss so Gene if you could
only
perform live on stage
again throughout your life or have sex
with all the women you had sex with
leave it leave it but you couldn't do
both which one would you go for
the women or the live performing
well I'm married now obviously Pierce
obviously and my lovely wife is right
outside I know and I'm going to ask her
the same question oh my God uh
uh well look uh doing what I do wearing
more makeup and higher heels than any
female you ever met literally
has been just unbelievable but sex is
pretty good too so which one why do you
have to pick well you've got to choose
it's a binary question
on stage because I knew I knew you'd say
that because you also get paid bam Well
you certainly get paid so from 76 to 79
it's become the biggest band in the
world you still hold the record of the
most gold albums money back you're sort
of 100 million records worldwide you've
told the world dozens of times and now
it's coming to an end the touring how do
you feel about that how do you really
feel about that I really feel proud uh
the best part was when I ran into my
buddy Paul Stanley who
uh we continue to have this astonishing
relationship and I've always been so sad
when Leonard McCartney and Jagger and
Richard started yes you know backbiting
I mean even Kane and Abel didn't get
along so well
uh it was always so sad to me and but
Paul and I have this resilient sort of
the brother I never had uh kind of a
thing and we don't agree on very much at
all but there's an abiding uh admiration
respect for
the talent that He has that I will never
have and hopefully the piece of the
puzzle that I bring to it that he
doesn't know that no question so that
one and one you have an amazing
chemistry it it works one and one is
three you don't know everything I don't
and when you meet somebody that's uh you
know kindred spirit you you can run and
be bigger than you ever were and at any
rate to cut to the chase
all good things have to come to an end
and you have to have the self-respect
and pride that's a big word
and the love of the fans to know when
the hell it's time to get off that stage
do you see a lot of bands who just oh
who go on too long look at that that
wasn't so long ago I don't remember
where that was this is in your farewell
tour yeah yes it is but all the shows
are like that right insane but you see
other bands go on too long is that they
go too long yeah and it's tough to give
it up you know this kind of AD right and
it's god-like you know I would love this
and uh but but at any rate when you
still look good when you still have uh
the physicality it takes to do that get
off the stage by the way it goes for
boxers too
um
Muhammad Ali Mike Tyson who's a friend
and so on these These are the greats of
all time and you've got you've got to
know when it's time to go I don't know
when to leave the party right I think
it's Sinatra said you must yeah so I got
an insight into your marketing genius
when we both appeared on Celebrity
Apprentice back in 2008 with Donald
Trump obviously was the host but what I
remember most was my first insane to you
as a businessman was we were told to do
a hot dog challenge we literally had to
sell hot dogs from a stand in Midtown
Manhattan actually outside the fox now
just a second Trump did not mention a
stand all he said was sell hundred
that's true that's true which is why
when we come to you but a genius so we
were deliberating as a group whether to
charge ten dollars or a hundred dollars
for our dogs
you picked your phone up and called a
mate and said will he give me five
thousand dollars for a hot dog ten was
it and he said okay and he said to me
I'll never forget this you said it's not
the vacuum cleaner that gets sold it's
the way the salesman sells the cleaner
and I've remembered that ever since yeah
it's true because that's really the
essence of where marketing takes a
business and explodes it right well if
you can if you can assess and everything
is about an assessment you know where
you go what road to take and so on if
you understand that it's not how many
units you sell but how much money you
make then it isn't always about units
sold it's about you know I'd rather sell
one Rolls-Royce than 20 Volkswagen right
right so it's not how many units it's
how much money can I make and the rules
were very clear I was listening sell hot
dogs didn't say where or when or all
that stuff and your uh you can't call
people you're in business with so I just
called people I knew and I said this is
for charity I'm not going to get any of
the money give me ten thousand I made a
few of those calls in the very first
phone call we beat the females we did
because it was with one call with one
dog because actually you understood how
to play the game which was brilliant you
also hold on but who won well I won
obviously but you know how I won because
I watched what you did I listened to
what you said and I thought yes and I
then hit my Rolodex and I then got a lot
of other people who came to help me in
the same way particularly in the final
lecture it was very interesting
um but you also took this obviously and
had done before then to the Rock
business in a way I don't think anyone's
ever done that as well as you guys did
with this well we make a living rob you
made an incredible franchise out of Kiss
where you have I think over 5 000 lines
of merchandise I just want to stop here
for a second because self-aggrandizement
and other big words like gymnasium I
enjoy hearing nice things said about me
but it's never just about you Paul's my
partner from the beginning you have the
right you have to surround yourself with
the right people who understand it so
you can go forth together but thank you
for the kind words five thousand
different pieces of mud should I do the
joke we literally
uh no joke intended we literally have
everything from Kiss condoms to kiss
caskets we'll get you coming and we'll
get you going there is a kiss toilet
seat oh yeah we've got a hair
you know the phrase sit down so well I
said on my face
so right there
of course these are semantics but we've
got a kiss lunchbox oh sure there are
many generations of course
well I think the point about it is you
just understood how to sell the band The
Business you guys well I'm not just in
the band I'm a fan of the band and I
remember uh when the Beatles first came
out there were a lot of beetle things
Beetle this Beetle that but then that
they never made the money they didn't
understand uh
you know the the marketplace and so on
because it was all brand new but we
wanted to be Disney without the overhead
right you could make an awful lot of
money if you understand everything by
the way I'm the only person on the
planet that owns the pound sign it's
trademarked right yeah I'll show it to
you including the euro because countries
are smart but not that smart they create
trademark laws but never trademark the
word England
public domain why well I had to
trademark that so I do own well you've
also got one of these which is a kiss
coffin casket yeah have you ordered one
of these for the when the time comes oh
no I think I'll
splatter I mean a shot or whatever it is
you know the dust particles and so on
but they also double and the bars have
them because they're moisture proof so
you put ice in it and people reach in
and have cold drinks out of it true how
much money have you made from Kiss oh
come on you that's the first question I
was going to ask you Pierce Morgan how
much money does it take justice
give me a number that's going to horrify
me no that's that's not fair I've read
that you're worth 400 million dollars
really yeah
I'll pull down
up or down what from 400. I I always
want to go up
but I tell you what here's a point for
all you folks out there I'm kind of a
big deal you go to your uh cell phone
and you type in into Google and smoogle
Jean Simmons gum
uh when I was singing the National
Anthem here for the NFL football team I
was chewing gum the day before and doing
soccer am the promotion thing and I was
chewing gum and they said Mr Simmons
please take out your gum and I because
I'm a wise guy I said eBay the next day
they put it on eBay how much Pierce
Morgan how much is he going for I asked
you first I let me guess five thousand
pounds would you like a tip
uh if I went to the Empire State
Building and pointed up how much would
that number be how much was it got
247 thousand dollars well for a piece of
guns I chewed by you Gene Simmons
that's true
you can Google and smuggle it talking of
Google what do you make of the tech
World we're now in what do you make of
Elon Musk and artificial intelligence
and all these I'm a big fan uh and like
like all people they're the ones that uh
change history and make life better on
Earth but they're the the single people
the the forward thinkers the futurists
change Life as We Know It Elon Musk is
undeniable he tried for years to get car
companies to go away from diesel fuel
and you know gas and so on they wouldn't
let so he did it himself it's always the
individual not the corporate entity
because you can move you can move fast
you don't have to make decisions by
committee I'm a big fan Twitter's going
to be fine yeah I totally agree with you
are you are you excited or are you
worried about artificial intelligence
particularly about the music business I
am concerned music business aside I am
concerned about the lack of legislation
when you enter a new let's say a new
planet you're about to land on new well
clearly there's opportunity there there
are minerals and things and so uh you
know all kinds of opportunities without
rules of of the game it's like Spain
playing sports without rules who's going
to do what you need some rules that are
you know kind and beneficial to mankind
women kind trans kind All Kinds of Kinds
okay does that cover everybody and so
probably not probably not well they're
always going to be new ones and you have
to respect all that subject aside the
problem with AI is not AI is here
whether you like it or not so let's look
at it smartly and let's pass legislation
AI creates a song using my voice or what
sounds like my voice with a new song and
it sounds just like me and it definitely
sounds like that kind of a thing so when
you're buying it who owns the copyright
and the publishing if AI did them so is
it me because it sounds like me you
could swear it was me so these are and
if it is you do you then care if if AI
does that we can make a deal
of course of course uh we're talking
you're making a deal let's come back off
the break with the best deal I think
you've made in your life which is
persuading your wife Shannon not just to
marry you but to stay with you that's
after the break
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
the boss finally we have you uh last
Tweed we have you right where I want
Gene to be
let me ask you straight off the top yeah
he when you met him was one of the
biggest rock stars in the world yeah I
didn't know that but yes would it
mattered if he was a plumber oh yeah
oh yeah I wouldn't have dated him I I
asked her Shannon if I didn't make a
good living and I'm going to try not to
exaggerate if I didn't make a good
living would you be with me and she said
see ya
but you must have known when you met him
I guess his reputation I did not um but
by the way no I I what did you mean I
grew up listening
at the Playboy Mansion really
um it was a party he came in with two
uh I don't know girls and um someone
suggested a producer friend of mine that
I go over and meet him my sister was
like come on come on let's go meet him I
said I don't know who that is it looks
kind of a little smarmy to me and uh so
I went over to meet him and you know we
got to talking and we had a lot in
common actually
um but the next day since there's no
cell phones or Internet and so on uh we
ran down to Tower Records to look him up
to make sure it was real because I
didn't believe the word he said and so
an entire section yeah it was kisses
yeah when you realized he was never
listened to that music before it was I
was Motown girl she just loves Tom Jones
that's it yeah yeah what was it that
made you fall in love with him
um it's smart and um
that's it
smart and Rich
and he's very romantic actually and um
did you make him cry yet he cried yeah
emotional yeah yeah I like that I was
surprised yeah is that really bad
boyfriend but uh very good Hospital well
that's interesting it almost is like
your relationship is two halves yeah up
to up to later it took 28 years for him
to grow up right yeah so but I waited oh
my God why did you wait many would have
gone I know I know and a lot of people
were like once your husband cheats on
you once they ditch and uh what about
when it's 5 000 times there's more what
there's more to him than that yeah he's
a of this he said that there's two
two Gene Simmons believe me I've heard
it huh yeah do you believe that yeah
sure oh yeah but I mean it's hard when
you're I now that I have a young man as
a child I know that you know when a girl
comes to your door and wearing a
raincoat with nothing under it and you
don't just go bye-bye
so uh I understand that it it happened
and meant almost nothing I've got a
picture of you on your wedding day ah
now this took a long time uh Gene for
you to persuade Shannon to get down
there what do you what do you both
remember that day I have to tell you
that I never wanted to get married and I
never had kids at least at least uh
consciously I didn't want to become my
father my father uh but he didn't know
he was his father
as far as far as the whole time really
you think that yes in what way because
his father was a philanderer and that's
why his mother left him and and so like
but he wasn't he was a philanderer and
um he came by it honestly and um uh but
you can't I mean I don't know how how
can you blame a musician well obviously
just knock you on your door when you
open it up but just you say what do you
say I didn't want to have kids because I
didn't want
kids feeling what I felt the world ended
I felt like what it I felt guilty what
did I do wrong that made my father get
up and leave without explaining anything
so
I and yet
am I doing okay she's not letting you
get away with a thing here no no you're
not getting off the hook in this one
what am I doing let me ask you a
different question okay what would you
say to your son for example or your
daughter if they ask you about these
stories where you've given interviews
we've talked about having thousands of
groupies what do you say to you your
kids if they ask those questions
at some point you gotta grow up I don't
know what to say except that uh there's
no look at that he said that's not he
said it was fun but it's over now
wow do you believe it is John I didn't
oh elf definitely
I I I cut off my schmeckle and I will
formaldo or she will put another
formalda put it on a pickle jar
you say I get I can now get what the
thing is with YouTube It's humor right
ultimately it's human you can't I mean I
could probably wallow in sorrow for a
long time but I mean has he broadly
though made you happier than not
absolutely yeah yeah and when you say
it's romantic how does that manifest
itself what's the most romantic thing
he's done for you oh my gosh I gave you
some cash yesterday
you know what it really does just give
me wands of cash yeah yeah
did you sell any guitars today yes I go
[Applause]
and when she gets to watch it goes like
this Gene what is what is true love
romantic the part though he did do the
the flower petals really yeah yeah yeah
yeah so what does true love mean to
Eugene because obviously you found it
with China but what what does it mean
painfully I
never confronted myself about that and
barely said I love you to my mother yeah
shockingly shamefully I I don't I was
always alone yeah that was a weakness
have you said it to Shannon yes
yes it happened much later
it happened much later I was afraid of
being weak of being weak vulnerable not
and not
I I never opened myself up to that you
know I always
it's hard you know the knight in shining
armor thing at least you have protection
around you and I never wanted to be hurt
ever again like now she's about to say
no I uh what can I say there's no school
for life and there's no school that says
okay this is what marriage is this is
what a relationship we're both learning
as we went along I'll say Young when I
met him too right what have you really
learned about yourself G
I've learned that I'm not so bad after
all
[Laughter]
would you agree I would I would yeah I
would say it's not so bad after all
yeah I really thought I was gonna
if it was going to be I look I'd been in
only two other relationships of any kind
never wanted sort of you weren't
faithful to them either
well one was Cher famously and Diana and
Donna Ross who was who you were with
before you mentioned philandering at the
same time he was yeah sure right with me
Shannon I mean you've got to admit I
mean go share Diana Ross mate you yeah
it's not bad
well that's not well but older women
with children than me oh stop it that's
fine let me finish Jimbo just I want to
show you again the picture of you and
your mum when you're eight years old
um because I think that she's obviously
been this constant presence throughout
everything in your life and really
formed I think a lot of your life yeah
when you look at yourself there what do
you see in that little boy
what was he hoping to be do you think
I'll just always
be being a big dreamer you wanted to
make her proud yes anything I wanted to
do was always about my mother and uh
you never drank or took drugs because of
her no I believe our children are the
same way yes no oh absolutely wanting to
make him do you think you did make your
proud did she tell you that yes
she uh
my mother she had shrined him in her
house said welcome home to my favorite
son it was up year round but my favorite
son she only had one son but what was
she what was she proudest of you think
of all the things you achieved no drugs
no alcohol no smoking be straight she
didn't approve of the stupid stuff she
kept telling me about don't do that to
shine account but I want to say that
um
my mother was bizarrely uh my biggest
fan when we'd land in New York on the
way to someplace else my mother would be
behind a pillar I I I'm not excited just
waving yes
I'm calm which is Hungarian my my time
my life
you should wave and go back behind the
pillar just
fundamentally when you look back over
everything you've achieved and had and
everything family professional do you
feel an enormous sense of gratitude to
your mother because without her it's
highly unlikely that Journey must have
happened nothing would have happened and
which is why mothers are the most
important life former on the face of the
planet without your mother peers you
wouldn't have become who you I totally
agree all our mothers our fathers mean
well and so on
but there's only one person who gave you
life and that's your mother and that's
Forever by the way I did a paper in
college
uh about the end of Life as we know it
for bad guys we're on death row and so
on the one word that keeps coming up or
the phrase that keeps coming up is
apologies to their mother before they go
to death isn't that interesting Jane
it's been brilliant I'm so glad we did a
much bigger interview great to have you
adding some Stardust at the end uh thank
you both very much indeed your time I
really appreciate it thank you
well that's it for me whatever up to I
think just keep it like Gene Sims Keep
It Uncensored good night
[Music]
good evening I'm Peters Morgan
uncensored in New York City tonight on
Piers Morgan uncensored in Kiev Ukraine
tonight on Piers Morgan on Special
Edition from cancer tonight a special
edition of Piers Morgan uncensored in
that battle though he's making me cry
again do you believe you can win this
war so are you gonna run again I think a
lot of people are going to be very happy
yes I feel betrayed they're trying to
force you out yes not only the coach but
the other two or three guys there around
all these people protesting just don't
get many of them don't isn't that
slightly patronizing
do you think we should have psychiatric
assessments
could you keep quiet I'm trying to read
a book
thanks bear and Chuck it where it
belongs in the bean
sexy where are they where's their
children
Maxwell agreed to be interviewed for the
very first time I obviously wish I'd
never met him you're shaking your head
your head British people are up in arms
Boris Johnson is out as British prime
minister the conservative party can
certainly win the
next can we yes
can we this is the royalty question is
did he say yes I have taken drugs and
they've bent the rules to give them the
Visa or lied on the visa application
form and therefore got it
foreign
[Music]